notre vision est claire pour EDF
l'énergie audition nationale est au cœur
de la transition énergétique du pays
c'est aussi la vision qui régnait il y a
près de 77 ans quand Marcel Paul un
ministre communiste a présidé la
création d'EDF
avec comme objectif un monopole de
l'énergéticien qui a conduit 77 ans plus
tard à l'électrification du pays elle a
construit
au monde nous en voyons nous en
bénéficions encore des fruits
aujourd'hui avec un mix électrique parmi
les moins émetteurs de gaz à effet de
serre au monde et parmi les plus
compétitifs
depuis 20 ans évidemment notre
énergéticien nationale a été affectée
pour du bon et du moins bon par
l'ouverture sur l'Union européenne avec
la loi de février 2000 sur la
modernisation du service public de
l'électricité et le sommet de Barcelone
en mars 2002 qui a conduit la
libéralisation du marché de
l'électricité et du gaz
certes le marché intégré à des défauts
et nous y travaillons reconnaissons
quand même tous ensemble que ce marché
est aujourd'hui le plus gros système
intégré en électricité du monde qui fait
quasiment tous les jours que quand la
France a besoin d'électricité elle peut
en apporter de ses voisins et
inversement quand elle en a trop elle
peut elle-même en exporter ailleurs
ayant vécu une dizaine d'années au
Québec qui depuis deux jours à un
million de Québécois privé d'électricité
je sais de quoi je parle et je vois
combien cette capacité de l'Europe à
avoir un marché de l'électricité
intégrée nous a été favorable notre
vision pourrait EDF est claire le groupe
Électricité de France est et restera un
instrument essentiel pour mettre en
œuvre la politique énergétique de l'État
français et au-delà un champion à
l'exportation aujourd'hui et ça a été
extrêmement bien spécifié dans la lettre
de mission du nouveau PDG l'ucrément
dont vous avez collectivement voté la
nomination à ce titre le sujet d'EDF
c'est essentiellement la production les
capacités opérationnelles et la conduite
des un projet industriel EDF a besoin
d'investir des dizaines de millions des
dizaines de milliards d'euros pardon
tous les ans pour lesquels il faut des
moyens et la crédibilité financière EDF
a besoin de retrouver sa maîtrise
industrielle dans le nucléaire EDF a
besoin de monter sur les énergies
renouvelables avec des objectifs
ambitieux pour les 30 prochaines années
pour cela le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités l'État a toujours
accompagné EDF dans ces opérations de
recapitalisation ce soit en 2017 en 2022
on n'a jamais autant investi dans le
nucléaire que depuis 2017 on va
évidemment accélérer tout ça mais il
faut quand même le reconnaître nous
avons sécurisé le calendrier de l'EPR 2
avec le projet de loi nucléaire que vous
avez voté en première lecture
EDF aujourd'hui est néanmoins une
société endettée une société avec de
gros besoins d'investissement c'est donc
conformément aux engagements pris par le
Président de la République durant sa
campagne que nous avons lancé dès cet
été une offre publique d'achat pour
prendre le contrôle à 100% du capital
d'EDF vous avez libéré 9,7 milliards de
crédits budgétaires avec cette
nationalisation nous renforçons les
moyens d'ef pour investir dans les
prochaines années et nous crédibilisons
sont sérieux financier vous le savez
l'offre publique d'achat est en cours de
finalisation d'ici début juin après
épuisement des derniers recours
répond donc aux vrais problématique du
groupe EDF et nous avons été il faut le
reconnaître un peu surpris quand cette
proposition de loi visant à nationaliser
EDF est tombé dans un calendrier un peu
surprenant et il faut le reconnaître
dans de l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale
flirtant parfois avec des théories du
complot cette PPL vise à répondre à des
angoisses qui n'ont aucun lieu d'être
Bruno Le Maire a eu l'occasion de le
dire à plusieurs reprises je les dis
moi-même devant la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale et je vous le
répète le projet Hercule est mort et
enterré il n'y a aucun projet ni visible
ni caché de démantèlement de notre
opérateur national
je salue le travail sénatorial qui
durant l'examen en commission a fait
preuve de sagesse en réécrivant une
bonne part du texte issue de l'Assemblée
nationale je salue particulièrement le
travail et l'esprit de responsabilité du
rapporteur pour cette remise à plat en
particulier le texte de la commission
supprime les articles 1 et 3 de
nationalisation du groupe EDF qui
pouvait fragiliser l'OPA en cours de
finalisation tout en arrivant reconnant
sur le à contretemps retire de l'article
2 les références aux activités d'un
groupe unifié dans le capital aurait été
totalement accessible qui rendait du
coup absolument impossible les
opérations courantes de gestion d'actifs
par EDF dont les trois milliards de
sessions d'actifs dans lequel
l'électricité l'électricien pardon
national et d'ores et déjà engagé
ce texte issu de la Commission modifie
également l'article 3 bis pour
restreindre le périmètre d'extension des
tarifs réglementés de vente au champ des
TPE qui ne sont pas encore éligibles sur
cette base nous avons donc matière avoir
une discussion je dirais apaiser et
constructive il nous reste malgré tout
deux points de désaccord sur lesquels je
souhaite attirer votre attention on y
reviendra évidemment dans le cadre de la
discussion des amendements d'une part
sur l'article 2 cet article inscrit dans
la loi que les tiens détient 100% du
capital d'EDF pas de problème avec ça
donc partageons cette proposition qui
redonne une place importante au
Parlement qui aurait ainsi à se
prononcer sur n'importe quel réouverture
du capital
il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur nos
intentations je le répète le projet
Hercule a été abandonné mais ça va sans
dire ça va peut-être mieux en l'écrivant
en revanche tel qu'il est formulé
aujourd'hui cet article prescrit
l'ouverture d'au moins 1,5% du capital
d'EDF aux salariés et anciens salariés
du groupe et ceux d'ici le premier
janvier 2024 je l'ai dit l'opéa n'est
pas encore terminé il nous reste
notamment à convaincre suite au recours
encore déposé à peu près 5% des
actionnaires à apporter leur titre dont
un certain nombre d'actionnaires
salariés il nous semblerait pour le
moins prématuré d'envisager de
l'intéressement les participations via
de l'actionnaire et salarié pour
quelques mois alors que nous viendrions
d'acheter les dix actions de la part des
salariés en question la situation
financière d'EDF il faut être clair ne
le permet pas aujourd'hui nous proposons
dans le cadre de la discussion un
amendement de compromis qui vise à
laisser ouverte la possibilité
d'actionnariat salarié pour l'avenir
tout en évitant de la forcer en la
rendant automatique et ce dès le premier
janvier prochain deuxième point de
discussion et j'en terminerai là vous
avez proposé l'extension du tarif
déréglementé du trve à toutes les TPE
alors qu'aujourd'hui il est réservé au
TPE petite consommatrice c'est peut-être
bien mais ça coûte cher monsieur le
Président gay d'abord il faut
reconnaître que ça remet en profondeur
en question la logique même du TRV qui
dans le cadre des discussions avec la
Commission européenne qui ont permis de
l'adopter visaient avant tout à protéger
les consommateurs ça veut dire comme
vous et moi et les petites entreprises
qui avaient elles-mêmes une consommation
similaire au ménage à être protégé par
ce tarif réglementé le discussion avec
la commission visait à ce que toutes les
entreprises qui ont une consommation je
dirais plus proche d'une consommation
industrielle soit elle au tarif de
marché la rédaction que vous avez
proposé est mieux rédiger elle limite le
champ au TPE elle pour autant elle
mettra en place une discussion complexe
il prendrait peu de temps avec la
Commission de régulation en électricité
avec la Commission européenne qui
prendrait sans doute bien bien plus
longtemps que nécessaire alors
qu'aujourd'hui notre objectif premier il
est de protéger les TPE les PME les ETI
et les grandes entreprises contre la
crise énergétique ça ne fait pas plus
long puisqu'on aura l'occasion de
discuter tout ça dans le cadre de la
discussion pour conclure vous rappeler
jusque nous sommes évidemment en phase
avec les objectifs réaffirmés par cette
PPL réécrite par nos soins avoir un
opérateur national de qualité inscrit
dans la durée qui pourra investir tout
ce qu'il faudra pour que les 77 ans qui
s'ouvrent soit aussi remplis de succès
que les 77 ans qui viennent de s'écouler
merci à tous et à toutes merci la parole
est maintenant rapportée en Gérard
longher importante de la commission des
finances
[Musique]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous examinons dans l'enthousiasme
général une PPE qui a été votée à
l'unanimité ou presque à l'Assemblée
nationale cette TPE présentée par
l'excellent député de l'heure Philippe
Brun ancien député ancienne
circonscription de Pierre Mendès France
a été voté à la quasi-animité ce qui
cache un profond malentendu dans les
intentions des différents députés qui se
sont exprimés à cette occasion
trois points dans ce texte de loi qui
nous vient de l'assemblée et pour lequel
la commission des finances au nom de
laquelle je rapporte a tenu à apporter
des modifications substantielles le
premier concerne Mayotte qui apparaît
mystérieusement bon on en a rapport sur
l'électricité de Mayotte qui appartient
pour partie au département pour partir à
EDF soit ce n'est pas l'habitude de
notre Assemblée d'accepter des rapports
mais il aurait été impossible de
trancher sur le fond dans les délais
d'études qui étaient donnés à notre
commission des finances le deuxième
point beaucoup plus important et qui
explique en grande partie qui explique
presque totalement le vote du groupe
auquel j'appartiens du groupe politique
auquel j'appartiens ici au Sénat et qui
a été le vote des lerres de l'Assemblée
c'est en effet le soutien apporté aux
entreprises la commission des finances a
estimé que nous pouvions faire sauter le
verrou du
transformateur de 36 kVA qui le veulent
a pourquoi parce qu'il divisait
inutilement la condition des artisans
qui pour les uns bénéficieraient du
bouclier fiscal pour la raison qu'il
serait en dessous et pour les autres
exerçant à peu près le même métier et
étant dans les normes de le de la
définition des TPE par l'Union
européenne ne pourrait pas en bénéficier
donc dès lors qu'on a moins de 10
salariés et moins de 2 millions de
chiffre d'affaires et quel que soit la
capacité de transformateurs nous
pourrons ils pourrons bénéficier du
bouclier tarifaire trve aller plus loin
on viendra dans le débat des amendements
aurait été impossible et dangereux
juridiquement
vis-à-vis des sociétés qui délivrent de
l'électricité que vis-à-vis de l'Union
européenne alors le troisième point est
beaucoup plus important il est
passionnant même c'est la crainte
exprimée avec force par l’auteur de la
PPL sur le risque de démembrement de DF
et là je crois il faut remercier
monsieur Brun parce que avec sa PPL il
nous oblige à réfléchir monsieur le
ministre chers collègue sur le marché de
l'électricité tel qu'il vient d'être
secoué depuis un peu plus d'un an et tel
qu'il peut évoluer dans l'avenir et
c'est ce marché de l'électricité
européenne qui doit donner aux
dirigeants de DF je dirais des
indications sur les libertés dont ils
doivent jouir pour diriger leur
entreprise une plus grande respect pour
Marcel Paul et pour des raisons
personnelles en plus mais nous ne sommes
plus en 19
le marché de l'énergie électrique et
libre pour la production ce qui n'était
pas le cas jusqu'en 2002 et il est libre
pour la vente aux consommateurs qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs petit ou grand que
l'on produise ou non de l'électricité et
personne en Europe ne songe à remettre
en cause cette liberté cette liberté et
ce marché ont-ils été catastrophique la
réponse est non en réalité entre
2015 et 2020 le prix moyen du spot s'est
situé entre 35 euros le mégawatt et 40
euros le mégawatts au point d'ailleurs
c'est une anecdote que la reine à 43 a
été moins sollicitée ou pas sollicité du
tout pendant cette période
je reviendrai sur la reine
nous avons donc un marché qui est libre
mais il y a de vraies questions qui ne
sont pas tranchées et qui relèvent
monsieur le ministre des négociations
intergouvernementales et ensuite du
Parlement européen d'une part confirmer
la liberté à laquelle sont attachées
l'immense majorité des Européens sur la
production et la distribution et la
vente d'électricité je dis bien la vente
d'électricité
et puis se poser la question Quels sont
les priorités de ce marché électrique
faut-il décarboner la société ou faut-il
la verdir pas tout à fait la même chose
si on décarbones on s'appuie sur le
nucléaire si l'on sait il s'agit
simplement de la verdir le malheur
nucléaire se retrouve confronté au même
difficulté de financement qui l'handicap
aujourd'hui
nous avons un deuxième sujet majeur à
l'aune de l'expérience la tragique
expérience russe fin du conflit pas du
conflit de l'invasion de la l'Ukraine
par la Russie
quel est le souci d'indépendance
acceptons-nous de placer l'indépendance
énergétique au rang qui doit être le
sien c'est à dire une principale
préoccupation celle qui avait d'ailleurs
inspiré
Georges Pompidou et Pierre Messmer
lorsqu'ils ont présenté en mars 1974 un
mois avant disparition du président
Pompidou le programme énergie le
programme nucléaire français sur lequel
nous vivons encore dans la lancée
donc question verdir ou décarbonée
question indépendante ou prit
occasionnel le meilleur marché ce qui a
été longtemps le gaz russe il faut le
reconnaître mais c'est aujourd'hui
frapper d'incertitude j'ajoute
peut-on imaginer une organisation du
marché qui dépend de moins du spot et
donc du coup marginal de la dernière
entreprise de production électrique
thermique en général allemand de
marchand de la ligne est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas avoir des systèmes différents
car le marché de l'électricité but sur
un problème que connaissent bien nos
amis électriciens c'est que
l'électricité ne se stocke pas et donc
la régulation est à peu près impossible
et les écarts de prix sont
spectaculaires ce qui aboutit quand on a
un marché qui fonctionne essentiellement
sur le coup marginal à des écarts de
prix qui sont à peu près insupportables
pour le consommateur j'ajoute que nous
sommes français fiers de notre
réalisation nucléaire on aimerait en
profiter un petit peu et de ne pas être
entraîné à la hausse par des cette
opérations du coût marginal donc
ces questions sur le marché sont
absolument préalables elle pèse déjà sur
le statut et c'est là où je m'adresse
non pas je m'adresse à vous mais au-delà
du Sénat à l'auteur de la PPL le
dénombrement de DF il existe en partie
le transport et la distribution pourquoi
parce que nous avons l'obligation au nom
de cette liberté
d'accepter l'accès des tirs au réseau et
comme il y a des monopoles techniques je
ne parle pas de monopole économique je
parle vrai de monopole technique il est
impensable de multiplier les réseaux
tant de transport que de distribution il
faut donc bien accepter que
RTE et enedis quoique propriété de la
puissance publique ou de d'EDF pour RTE
puisse
être indépendant d'un défaut d'un des
utilisateurs des réseaux mais qui n'est
que aujourd'hui l'un des utilisateurs du
réseau
cette première différence vaut aussi
pour la question que j'évoquais à
l'instant qui est la question de la
reine parce que la règne c'est ça se
termine en 2025 nous sommes à la fin de
la reine et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
on s'appelle faut-il maintenir ce
système faut-il se contenter d'augmenter
le prix faut-il imaginer ce qui serait
peut-être intelligent un système tech
orteil c'est-à-dire ou bien vous prenez
ou bien vous payer une certaine somme je
suis quelqu'un des assurances après tout
l'assurance parraîchère qu'avant
l'accident on la paye tout le temps même
quand on n'a pas d'accident et quand on
a un accident on est content d'être
assuré la reine a joué ce rôle
d'assurance sauf que c'est une assurance
qu'on paye après l'accident ce qui est
évidemment beaucoup plus facile c'est
comme gagner sur les courses de chevaux
après l'arrivée et bien
système là de la reine est au cœur des
préoccupations de même nous avons des
fournisseurs extrêmement sérieux y
compris français d'électricité qui
accepteraient volontiers de participer
au financement du nucléaire français non
pas pour l'exploiter Dieu les engagent
enfin Dieu ou la SN ou l'URSS je ne sais
pas mais en tous les cas il ne souhaite
pas exploiter il souhaite simplement
financer pour avoir des droits de tirage
avec une certaine stabilité on pourrait
même imaginer nous législateur après
tout savoir de notre rôle de conduire
les
fournisseur les entreprises qui
revendiquent de fournir de l'électricité
de garantir 70% de l'approvisionnement
par des contrats à long terme que la
Commission jusqu'à présent refuse et
donc je me dis vous avez un formidable
combat mais c'est quand on verra les
éléments de ce combat les points gagnés
les points hauts contrôlés et puis les
malheureusement les embuscades dans tel
ou tel règlement que nous pourrons nous
retourner vers les dirigeants d'EDF en
leur disant attention là vous avez une
opportunité qu'il ne faut saisir ou au
contraire vous avez un risque qu'il faut
assumer et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me retourne vers vous d'abord mais
vers Philippe Brun également en lisant
votre PPL elle est elle sera parfaite
quand on connaîtra quand on ne connaîtra
les règles du jeu définitif aujourd'hui
et les prématurés et donc je propose une
mesure conservatoire 100% du capital
l'État à la main le Parlement est en
pleine responsabilité et laissons à
chacun faire son métier et ils ont
confiance en nos électriciens et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
accepté et c'est terminé de faire d'EDF
une une fierté nationale c'est dans le
texte
[Applaudissements]
en fait
vous savez que nous sommes dans des
niches que le temps est contraint donc
je demanderai à chacun des orateurs par
respect pour les porteurs de ces
propositions de loi de respecter leur
temps de parole de façon à ce que l'on
puisse finir les deux PPL merci
monsieur bien que vous avez la parole
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique social européen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mais
chers collègues alors que le doute plane
sur l'avenir du groupe PDF et malgré
l'abandon du projet Hercule les députés
ont voté la proposition de loi visant à
la nationalisation du groupe PDF mais au
Sénat il a été rebaptisé protéger le
groupe électricien de France donne des
membres man
le spectre d'excuse ne fait pas
totalement dissiper et nourrit des
inquiétudes il vivait à réorganiser des
F pour subvenir aux investissements
nécessaires d'une part pour prolonger la
durite du parc nucléaire d'autre part
développer les énergies renouvelables
sans oublier le père il vivait à créer
trois entités la première regroupant
nucléaire et réseaux de transport la
deuxième associé en commercial
la troisième incluelle des barrages
hydroélectriques avec un risque c'est de
vendre par appartement les branches les
plus rentables du premier opérateur
européen d'électricité
selon la formule consacrée
socialisent les pertes et privatisons
les profits on comprend mieux les
craintes des auteurs du texte le doute
que nous allons connaître quoi qu'on en
dise une croissance exponentielle du
prix et de la consommation de
l'électricité au rythme du développement
d'activités très énergivore comme celle
du numérique avait sa courte de serveur
informatique ou encore du choix d'un
business model un industriel du tout
électrique pour les véhicules
automobiles dans ce contexte aggravé par
une géopolitique européenne
internationale
nous devons déterminer nos orientation
avec la plus grande prudence l'État doit
garder la maîtrise des infrastructures
stratégiques qui sont la production et
la distribution d'électricité
garantissant l'indépendance énergétique
du pays sa dynamique économique est
l'approvisionnement des foyers français
d'autres facteurs doivent être prises
encore comme par exemple l'interaction
entre les métiers de la filière qui doit
être garantie par la puissance publique
quant à l'article 2 modifia le code de
l'énergie là aussi vidé de sa substance
il oblige à passer par la loi en cas de
tentative de privatisation des activités
d'EDF
depuis la production le transport
lècheportation jusqu'au prestations de
maintenance et de sécurité
à titre personnel
sans rétablissement de l'article premier
à l'issue de nos débats je ne voterai
pas ce texte car je n'oublie pas
l'inquiétude des Français et du
gouvernement face au spectre des
coupures d'électricité durant l'hiver
qui vient de s'achever je vous remercie
vous êtes parfait
la parole est maintenant Madame
Christine Navarre pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur alors la
PPL dont nous allons discuter de cet
après-midi traite de trois sujets le
dernier sans lien direct avec les deux
premiers que j'aborderai succès vivement
à savoir la nationalisation d'EDF sont
possibles des membrement et enfin
l'extension des tarifs réglementés de
vente de l'électricité alors sur la
nationalisation sans grande surprise le
groupe les républicains soutient le
travail du rapporteur et dont je
remercie ici et ça déjà été fait la
qualité qui a supprimé l'article premier
qui prévoyait la nationalisation alors
nous ne disons pas pour autant que la
garantie du non privatisation d'une
activité hautement stratégique au même
titre ADP ne se pose pas et je vous
renvoie tous ici à ceux qui ont
participé au débat de la loi pacte en
effet la souveraineté énergétique de la
France repose sur EDF dont l'état
possédait déjà 84% des parts du capital
toutefois une montée au capital pour
passer à 100% et actuellement prévu 9
milliards 7 ont d'ailleurs été votés
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
fusionnément rectificative au mois de
juillet dernier dans le cadre d'une
offre publique d'achat simplifié à un
prix de 12 euros par action qui a été
validé par le conseil d'administration
d'EDF alors cette opération elle
présente un inconvénient à savoir que la
procédure échappe presque totalement au
contrôle du Parlement et c'est
d'ailleurs une des critiques qu'on
exprimée les députés les républicains
tout en reconnaissant que la
nationalisation n'était certainement pas
la meilleure réponse à apporter et donc
nous partageons également cette position
l'eau passe étant en cours la
nationalisation n'a pas de justification
alors par cette offre publique d'achat
en fait les tâches à se donner les
moyens de mettre en oeuvre une politique
de relance du nucléaire nous avons envie
de vous croire même si c'est quand même
votre majorité je suis obligé de le
rappeler qui a mis fin au programme
Astrid en 2019 et je parle là sous le
contrôle du vice-président de l'OPEX
dont notre collègue Stéphane piennois a
commis un rapport publié en juillet 2021
qui justement met en avant toutes les
méfaits de cet abandon pour la stratégie
énergétique française alors Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement relancer le
nucléaire est un défi technique quel
type de réacteur allons-nous construire
mais c'est aussi et surtout un défi
financier aujourd'hui le groupe EDF est
très endetté j'ai regardé 64,5 milliards
de dettes afin 2022 les investissements
pour le nucléaire sont considérables
alors qu'ils pour le nouveau nucléaire
alors qu'il faut en même temps financer
le programme de grand carénage près de
60 milliards d'euros en tenant compte
des impératifs d'adaptation au
changement climatique la commission des
finances a travaillé très récemment sur
le sujet alors en mars 2021 Bercy estimé
que le programme de 6 opère 2 offrent
financier pour écouter entre 52 et 57
milliards d'euros je cite dans un
scénario de bonne maîtrise industrielle
mais pour aller jusqu'à 64 milliards
d'euros dans un scénario plus dégradé
alors Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous en dire plus sur votre stratégie de
financement j'ai cru le lire ou
comprendre qu'un appel aux investisseurs
étrangers pourraient être envisagé cela
ressort d'une visio qui a eu en janvier
2021 l'ancien patron d'EDF à savoir
Jean-Bernard Lévy ou encore qu'il
pourrait être fait appel au front du
Liberia qui jusqu'à présent me semble
être contre consacré au financement du
logement social donc vous l'avez bien
compris monsieur le ministre si nous
n'avons pas d'opposition à cette offre
publique d'achat nous avons de
véritables interrogations sur le
financement de la stratégie qui est
poursuivie et à court terme cette OPA
celle pose une seule question qui est
celle du devenir des actionnaires
salariés alors depuis le 8 février 2023
date de clôture provisoire de l'offre
les tiens des tas l'état des tiens près
de 96% du capital
1,17% restent encore soutenu par les
salariés donc aujourd'hui rien n'oppose
n'empêche l'État en fait de se retirer
de la cote ça c'est techniquement
possible avec plus de 90% du capital
mais on remarque quand même que la
clôture définitive de l'opération a été
retardée notamment aujourd'hui parce que
l'État fait face à un procès de petits
actionnaires qui portent notamment sur
le prix de rachat des actions qui est
jugé trop faible alors dans les faits le
prix de rachat fixé à 12 euros constitue
en fait une prime par rapport à la
valorisation du marché de court terme de
l'entreprise je vous rappelle qu'au mois
de juillet l'action est descendue après
de 7 euros mais pour les salariés qui
regardent en fait le prix auquel ils ont
acheté à savoir
20 32 euros pour les non salariés et
25,6 euros en 2005 pour les salariés
c'est une véritable perte puisqu'il y a
une division par plus de deux du cours
si on ajoute à ça l'inflation autant
vous dire que la perte est encore
beaucoup plus importante
alors ces petits actionnaires au nombre
de 82 000 salariés ou anciens salariés
ils souhaitent être maintenu au capital
et la justice se penchera enfin rendra
sa décision dans le procès en cours le 2
mai prochain alors pour cranter dans la
loi le passage d'EDF à 100% dans le
giron de l'État la commission des
finances à l'initiative de Gérard
Longuet a inscrit dans la pépel
l'objectif d'une détention du capital à
hauteur de 100% au plus tard le 1er
jumier 2024 et dans le texte initial de
la commune dans le texte de la
commission celui dont nous discutons 2%
de ce capital pouvait toutefois être
accordée aux salariés aux anciens
salariés d'EDF alors je vous avoue et
nous en avons eu des discussions en
commission des finances que je
m'interroge en fait sur la mise contre
la mise en oeuvre concrète de cette
disposition notamment puisque dans la
mesure où l'off public d'achat prévoit
une montée à 100% du capital par l'État
on se demande ensuite comment il serait
possible dans rétrocéder 2%
aux salariés je m'interroge aussi sur
l'intérêt en fait pour les petits
actionnaires parce qu'ils vont se
trouver avec une action qui n'est pas
liquide à partir du moment où
l'entreprise n'est plus cotée par
ailleurs en fait aujourd'hui il faut
quand même se le dire je vous ai parlé
de la date mais l'entreprise n'est pas
du tout profitable en 2022 elle a fait
près de 18 milliards d'euros de pertes
alors pour différentes raisons
l'existence du mécanisme d'arène ce
mécanisme doit disparaître en janvier
enfin en 2025 on ne connaît pas des
suites qui seront donnés mais ces suites
ont des conséquences très fortes sur la
rentabilité du groupe
voilà et ça c'est des vrais sujets sur
lequel il va falloir avoir des
explications et donc aujourd'hui je me
demande si en fait un versement de
dividendes sera possible pour ses
salariés pour ces actionnaires tant les
besoins d'investissement sont très
importants aujourd'hui déjà en fait en
termes de trésorerie EDF empreinte entre
1,5 et 3 milliards d'euros par an pour
venir verser des dividendes et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
depuis 2016 en fait l'état ne demande
plus de versement de dividendes en cash
mais récupère en fait avec des
des actions une montée de capital pour
justement soulager la trésorerie de
l'entreprise alors j'ai bien vu que le
gouvernement a déposé un amendement à la
proposition de la commission dont
j'avoue ne pas avoir beaucoup mieux
compris en quoi il serait il répondrait
mieux entre guillemets à ses
interrogations donc je nous aurons je
pense très certainement l'occasion dans
des battre tout à l'heure sur le démon
de Broman je vais pas rappeler ici le
projet Hercule qui avait été envisagé en
2019 qui a été abandonné depuis juste
pour vous dire que le groupe LR du Sénat
lui n'a pas d'opposition de principe à
ce qui a pu être écrit dans une note
adressée à l'autorité des marchés
financiers à savoir poursuivre le plan
de section d'actifs à hauteur d'environ
3 milliards d'euros entre 2022 et 2024
nous n'avons pas d'opposition dès lors
bien sûr que cette décision
participeront d'une stratégie d'entre
d'indépendance énergétique et de
décarbonation donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous soutenons pleinement la
réécriture de l'article 2 l'état
possèdera désormais une entreprise qui
dans le cadre fixé par le code de
l'énergie et cette nouvelle rédaction
elle permet notamment de lever un
certain nombre de risques qui pesaient
sur les filiales de DF et notamment RTE
enfin et pour finir sur les extensions
des tarifs réglementés de vente alors
les députés socialistes eux ont prévu
une mesure qui est d'une part d'un coup
financier très important alors le
gouvernement nous annonce 18 milliards
pour tous ceux qui étaient dans cette
mission au mois de décembre j'avoue que
nous avons toujours maintenant de une
suspicion en fait quand le gouvernement
nous annonce des chiffrages en matière
de dispositif d'énergie nous nous
souvenons d'un sous amendement
assimilard et enfin comme nous attendons
toujours les chiffres à l'appui des
assertions qui ont été faites au mois de
décembre nous vous accorderons un crédit
limité sur le coût de la mesure mais
j'entends que ça doit quand même être
très onéreux puisque l'application de
l'article 13 du règlement européen
d'octobre 2022 prévoit que l'État dans
des mises et les fournisseurs dès lors
qu'ils vendent à perte enfin cette
extension aux entreprises de taille
intermédiaires les GTI lui et contraire
endroits européens puisque les aides
d'État sont temporaires sont possibles
uniquement pour les TPME donc par contre
nous vous rejoignons sur l'objectif de
la mesure qui était en fait d'apporter
une réponse au petites entreprises que
les boulangers particulièrement mais
aussi au collectivités dont certaines en
fait se trouvent exclus des tarifs
réglementaires alors même qu'elle
remplissent les critères de chiffre
d'affaires ou de budget et de nombre de
salariés mais elles ont un besoin de
souscrire une puissance installée forte
parce que par exemple pour une
collectivité c'est une grosse pompe à
chaleur pour les boulangers c'est un
four et donc cette solution de supprimer
la mention de 36 Cavers elle est très
pertinente je veux juste vous faire
remarquer ici qu'en fait dès le début on
aurait pu le faire parce que il me
semble que ça relève du pouvoir
réglementaire et qu'il aurait été
beaucoup plus facile de corriger une
erreur dans domaine du règlement que de
devoir corriger une erreur dans la loi
et enfin pour finir juste pour vous dire
qu'à l'instar de ce que mon collègue
Daniel grimillier avait pu dire au
moment de l'ouverture du texte sur le
nucléaire aujourd'hui j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'il nous manque une
vision c'est à dire que depuis plusieurs
mois on parle de briques briques sur le
nucléaire brique sur les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui brique sur EDF
mais on n'a pas vraiment le plan du mur
qu'on est en train de construire alors
vous allez me dire que tout ça va
arriver bientôt puisque
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Capu
pour 4 minutes pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues le problème d'une
entreprise nationale c'est que sa
stratégie dépend du calendrier électoral
c'est une évidence qu'il me semble utile
de rappeler en préambule alors que des
éloges de l'État actionnaire vont fuser
à gauche comme à droite
or les cycles d'investissement
industriels s'inscrivent dans le temps
long il s'accorde mal avec le calendrier
électoral
aujourd'hui un consensus politique c'est
pourtant formé autour de la
nationalisation def ce point d’accord
est un fait rare car en matière de
politique énergétique l'accord et
l'exception et le désaccord la règle
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale il n'y
a eu que deux grands accords historiques
le premier c'est le Conseil National de
la Résistance
les auteurs de la proposition de loi s'y
réfèrent d'ailleurs abondamment et nos
collègues socialistes salut l’œuvre du
général de Gaulle avec une ferveur qui
je l'avoue ne laisse pas insensible
le second accord historique c'est le
virage du tout nucléaire avec le plan
Messmer de 1974 grande année la France
s'est alors engagée dans la construction
du plus grand parc nucléaire au monde je
pensais pas à ça
se développements industriel n'a pas été
remise en cause par les gouvernements
suivants cette remarquable constance a
permis à EDF de bâtir un actif
stratégique hors du commun qui a très
largement contribué à la prospérité de
la France grâce à une électricité
abondante et peu cher
pour justifier la nationalisation d'EDF
les auteurs du texte dressent le
parallèle entre la France de 2023 et
celle de 1946 mais à vrai dire mes chers
collègues la situation actuelle
ressemble bien plus au premier choc
pétrolier qu'à la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la crise énergétique découle
d'une guerre qui ne se lui produit pas
sur notre sol mais nous dont nous
suitons indirectement les conséquences
et qui nous obligent à agir
et d'ailleurs comme il y a 50 ans la
nation se rassemble aujourd'hui autour
d'un objectif garantir la souveraineté
énergétique en construisant de nouveaux
réacteurs c'est tout le projet me
semble-t-il du gouvernement qui a
annoncé reprendre la possession de DF
afin de garder la maîtrise du parc
nucléaire
nos collègues socialistes reprochent
encore au gouvernement de nationaliser
EDF pour mieux la saucissonner c'est
assez fort de café alors que c'est la
gauche qui a orchestré la mise à mal de
la filière nucléaire française sous
François Hollande
puisqu'on sait depuis 2015 qu'il suffit
d'une loi pour fragiliser l'avenir de
notre industrie nucléaire je ne suis pas
certain qu'une proposition de loi
pourrait garantir quoi que ce soit
pour moi les choses sont assez claires
le gouvernement veut nationaliser UDF
elle Parlement soutient cette initiative
le reste n'est que spéculation sur
l'avenir
à l'initiative de notre collègue Gérard
Longuet rapporteur la commission des
finances a largement réécrit le texte je
salue ses travaux notre groupe préfère
très nettement cette nouvelle mouture et
qui a le mérite de limiter la portée
législative du texte cette version a
également le mérite de mettre en
conformité ce texte avec le droit
européen alors que l'Europe à plus que
jamais besoin d'union face à la Russie
face à la Chine fasse même parfois à nos
alliés américains il ne s'agit pas là
d'un détail c'est la raison pour
laquelle le groupe se partagera entre un
vote positif et une abstention je vous
remercie
merci ma parole est maintenant Monsieur
Daniel brouiller pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission chers
collègues je salue la proposition de loi
présentée et portée par Philippe Brun à
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'inscrit
pleinement dans la dynamique du projet
des écologistes pour une république
écologique dans le cadre des
présidentielles 2022
renationaliser Électricité de France et
en faire un outil stratégique puissant
cohérent au service de la transition
énergétique alors bien sûr la commission
des finances a supprimé le premier
article de cette proposition de loi qui
formalisait un acte de nationalisation
préférant une étatisation à supprimer
l'énumération des filiales constitutives
du groupe public unifié visant à
s'opposer au démantèlement du groupe
bref la commission des finances a
décousu cette PPL bien que le projet
Hercule je vous entends monsieur le
ministre s'il n'existe plus caché un
Hercule bis les choix énergétiques pour
notre pays peuvent diverger d'autres
sont ici largement minoritaires et vous
les connaissez mais lorsque l'on défend
le choix du nucléaire on doit aussi
défendre un outil 100% public chaque
décision de l'État bouclier tarifaire
relèvement des volumes de la reine grand
carénage construction de 6 EPR pèsent
sur les comptes de DF dont la situation
est déjà particulièrement dégradée à
cela s'ajoute l'incompréhension totale
des Françaises et des Français sur le
coup de l'énergie l'énergie l'accès à
l'énergie joue aussi un rôle social et
sociétal c'est un bien de première
nécessité qui comme l'eau doit être
traitée en ce sens un bien commun
essentiel les 15% de restent à charge du
bouclier tarifaire non pas le même
impact selon qu'on habite une passoire
thermique qu'on est en situation de
précarité ce sont les revenus modestes
qui sont malheureusement toujours les
premières victimes de ces hausses du
coût de la vie les bailleurs sociaux
craignent une hausse des impayés les
syndicats de copropriétaires font face
également à des difficultés nouvelles
comme les artisans commerçants
vpme et je souligne sur ce point notre
accord avec l'amendement du rapporteur
pour supprimer le plafond des 36
kwa seul un tiers des entreprises
concernées par le bouclier tarifaire on
concrétisé une demande d'aide les
collectivités quant à elles ne savent
toujours pas dans quelle mesure elle
bénéficieront ou non des aides de l'État
la PPA l'initiale propose un accès pour
tous au tarif réglementés on pourrait
attendre de la chambre des territoires
un plein soutien à cette revendication
de bon sens pour nos collègues mère la
situation est grave les écologistes a
l'air depuis de nombreuses années sur
l'urgence à s'engager fortement dans les
énergies décarbonées sur la fin de
l'abondance la mise hors marchés et or
surconsommation de l'énergie si l'État
ne peut pas tout prévoir il a une
obligation de préparer l'avenir la
concurrence ouverte la politique du prix
bas des stratégies tout nucléaires
encore aujourd'hui ne favorise pas selon
nous une réorientation des politiques
énergétiques en cohérence le rapport du
GIEC et les dérèglements climatiques et
encore moins une maîtrise des coûts qui
est pourtant espérée souvent proclamé
sur ses bancs EDF pourrait redevenir le
bras armé de notre pays pour une
nouvelle politique énergétique la
proposition de loi de Philippe Brun
répond à cette axe majeur et stratégique
du retour de DF sous le contrôle de
l'État il serait inadmissible de voir
les aspects rentables du groupe comme le
développement des énergies renouvelables
être privatisées selon la bonne vieille
méthode libérale prisatrice privatisée
les bénéfices et nationaliser les pertes
et les déficits j'accevrai j'achèverai
ce propos en évoquant la place des
citoyens et des salariés dans ce débat à
quel moment les Françaises et les
Français ont-ils été associés à ces
décisions et aux orientations prises par
le gouvernement serait-il d'accord pour
financer des réacteurs dont le modèle je
voudrais le rappeler on l'oublie souvent
Flamanville 1 19,1 milliard d'après la
Cour des comptes quand il devait en
coûter 3,3 un débat national sur les
choix énergétiques de la France est
indispensable il est même essentiel ces
choix ne peuvent se faire sans une
nation éclairée aux enjeux climatiques à
leurs conséquences pour l'avenir les
expressions en discussion générale que
nous venons d'entendre l'ont montré il y
a en réalité dans cette émission deux
approches très différentes
seul libéral très libéral de la
commission des finances et de son
rapporteur Gérard Longuet qui laisse
ouverte toutes les options de cession
ultérieure de filiales
et celle la nôtre
centrée sur le confortement de notre
souveraineté industrielle en matière
d'énergie des carbonée
nous voulons garder dans le giron
national EDF et toutes ces filiales cœur
de métier la production dans toutes ses
formes énergies renouvelables
hydraulique nucléaire thermique le
transport et la distribution RTE et
enedis sans rien toucher au prérogatives
et aux statut particulier eu égard au
droit européen qui sont les leurs ainsi
que les services services énergétiques
que rend le groupe aujourd'hui comme les
imports et les exports d'électricité
monsieur le ministre vous avez laissé
entendre que c'était le marché européen
qui avait institué de l'exportation et
de l'importation
l'exportation et l'importation
existaient bien avant la mise en place
du marché européen je tiens à le
rappeler ici
comme je tiens à dire que porter la part
du capital de dfsa à 100%
pour l'État n'empêchera pas des sessions
de capital ou de filiales
ultérieurement et je regrette la porte
reste ouverte pour des opérations de
restructuration comme Hercule
voilà
l'objet de ce texte était de garantie
d'apporter des garanties par rapport à
ça ça ne sera pas le cas donc ce que
nous voulons je le répète c'est une
société EDF nationalisée dans le cadre
d'un groupement public unifié et ça sera
le sens des amendements que nous allons
défendre
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Victor
Hurel
président
oui
le groupe auquel
j'appartiens
à la nationalisation à une loi de
nationalisation de l'entreprise
EDF
EDF n'est pas une simple entreprise
c'est une arme c'est un bouclier
et penser un seul instant qu'une
opération
[Musique]
simplifiée une offre publique d'achat
donc une étatisation donc une montée en
capital suffit pour garantir l'unité la
cohérence l'intégration et éviter les
dérives que l'on a pu constater pendant
une vingtaine d'années dans la gestion
et le management de cette entreprise est
une illusion c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous tenons au principe de la
nationalisation inscrite dans le
préambule de la constitution de 46 est
repris dans le bloc de constituation
qui est le nôtre à savoir ça doit
devenir bien commun bien de la nation
qui doit être transférer ses moyens de
production transférées mais surtout
utile bénéfice des nationaux voilà ce
que l'on dit pour autant on ne dit pas
de s'enfermer et de ne pas faire dans
l'International on ne dit pas ne pas
faire dans la rotation d'actifs on veut
préserver le cœur de métier de EDF c'est
la raison de notre amendement savoir une
entreprise nationalisée
est-ce que c'est vous qui présentez
l'amendement numéro 2
c'est fait mais je le répète ça me donne
juste un temps pour dire on veut
consolider et unifier EDF et tenir à ce
que Philippe Brun appelait un groupe
public unifié on le fait pour la SNCF
j'ai entendu moi des arguments assez
spéciaux pour dire oh c'est une simple
occurrence et qu'on ne pourrait pas le
répéter non on le répète et on a vu nos
collègues communistes Fabien gay déposer
un amendement sur le CNR pour dire mais
ça s'appelle bien une société anonyme
intégrée
intégré et bien on l'a proposé en
commission ça a été refusé le mot
national a été retenu mais on tient donc
à cette entité et à au concept de
national et de nationalisation
merci alors avant de donner la parole à
Fabien gay pour présenter l'amendement
numéro 8 qui est identique j'informe le
Sénat et que je suis saisie d'un
chapelet de demande de scrutin public
sur ces articles et ce qui vous
permettra de vous préparer allez-y
quand on peut appeler ça un chapelet
merci Madame la Président Monsieur le
mini mes chers collègues nous nous
tenons comme nos collègues socialistes
au retour de l'article 1er et au terme
nationalisation parce que ce n'est pas
exactement sur le ministre ce que vous
êtes en train de faire en rachetant les
actions des actionnaires minoritaires
qui étaient institutionnels ou
actionnariat salariés ce que vous faites
en ce moment c'est une étatisation et
vous sortez EDF de la Bourse
c'est-à-dire que EDF ne sera plus côté
en bourse ça sera donc une entreprise
qui aura un capital 100% public mais
dans lequel et vous le savez très bien
puisque ça sera toujours sa structure
une sa société anonyme vous créerez une
holding comme vous avez fait la SNCF et
d'autres entreprises publiques ce qui ne
vous empêchera pas deux choses d'abord
un de filialiser la deuxième chose de CD
des actifs dont Dalkia enedis et il va
falloir que votre gouvernement réponde
est-ce que oui ou non vous voulez céder
Dalkia enedis et la troisième chose
c'est que la holding de tête sera 100%
national mais ça vous empêchera pas en
réalité de céder aussi et d'ouvrir à des
filiales à des capitaux privés et donc
ce n'est pas exactement la même chose
que vous êtes en train de faire et le
projet que nous voulons la
nationalisation et je me permettrai mais
dans un débat à gauche tranquillement je
pense que nous devrions ajouter à
nationalisation la transformation de la
société mais elle sort en épique et
tamisement public que nous connaissons
extrêmement bien donc ce ne sont pas des
fonctionnaires ce sont des assimilés et
le statut des IOG va avec mais la
transformation en épique elle nous
garantit d'autres choses donc je vous le
dis monsieur le ministre il nous tenons
à ce que l'article 1er soit rétabli
comme l'avait adopté l'Assemblée
nationale merci
y a-t-il d'autres
pardon il a vu de la Commission sur ces
deux âmes
identiques monsieur le ministre
défavorable également monsieur Montaugé
pour une explication de vote merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
je redis ici la nécessité de
nationaliser le groupe EDF
pour éviter tout démantèlement ou des
membres Man et d'ores et déjà ce stade
du débat je voudrais attirer votre
attention et ça permettra peut-être au
ministre de nous répondre dans quelques
instants sur la la problématique parce
que ça n'est une des 2% de capital
propriétés des salariés
cette disposition va fragiliser
l'hydraulique la production hydraulique
et probablement réouvrir le débat
relatif à la mise en concurrence des
concessions hydrauliques
donc ça serait ça serait une première
étape de démantèlement de démembrement
de l'entreprise obligatoire
qu'évidemment on veut éviter et qu'on
pourrait éviter effectivement en votant
cet article premier appelant à la
nationalisation du groupe EDF
c'est pas une petite affaire
c'est avéré en termes de risque
juridique et je voudrais que le
gouvernement peut être le rapporteur
nous éclaire là dessus
parce que les conséquences pourraient
être considérable considérable je vous
remercie
merci je vais donc monsieur BRI à vous
de la parole
merci madame la Présidente je comprends
bien sûr le choix de l'étatisation fait
par le gouvernement et soutenu par le
rapporteur la situation actuelle de DF
le coût du grand carénage le coût très
optimiste des 6 premiers européens ou
trois fois moins cher que flamant ville
tout ça suppose effectivement qu'il
puisse y avoir un acteur public
c'est-à-dire nous-mêmes les
contribuables pour venir
financer ses dépenses considérables
mais ça n'est rien à voir avec le projet
initial de nationalisation c'est un
autre choix qui a été proposé par nos
collègues et qui est défendu sur ces
bancs de la gauche le choix d'avoir
effectivement un outil des politiques
énergétiques donc évidemment je voterai
ces deux amendements identiques de mes
collègues l'urlaient les gay au nom de
mon groupe et je le redis il est temps
d'avoir un débat sur la politique
énergétique de notre pays et pas de
débattre par petites tranches tranches
de pair tranche d'accélération ou débat
de cet après-midi de ces sujets bien
s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication de vote sur ces amende
monsieur
coucou madame la Président je sais qu'il
faut avancer non mais je trouve dommage
quand même que en une minute le ministre
nous répond pas quand même on a posé des
questions sur la question la différence
entre rétaphatisation et nationalisation
et on vous pose une question simple
est-ce que vous vous engagez ici devant
le Parlement en CD aucun actif enedis et
dalkera par exemple pourrait nous dire
ce que vous êtes très à propos pour dire
il y aura pas d'Hercule très bien on en
doute mais est-ce qu'il y aura oui ou
non des sessions d'actifs puisque il y a
pas de projet caché dites-le ici devant
le Parlement engagez-vous au moins sur
cette question je vous remercie madame
la présidente
d'une gouvernement
la présidence cet amendement me permet
d'évoquer le sujet de l'actionnaire un
salarié évoqué dans leur discussion
générale ou dans la discussion
d'amendement par un certain nombre des
sénateurs et des sénatrices ici présente
nous proposons
[Musique]
je dirais de rendre possible de
l'actionnariat salarié au sein de
l'entreprise EDF même si pour être très
clair nous ne jugeons cette absolument
ni souhaitable ni même envisageable à
très court terme pourquoi parce qu'on
est justement en train de racheter 100%
du capital pour restaurer la capacité
financière de l'entreprise la capacité
par non opérationnelle et sa capacité à
investir donc non seulement faire ce
genre d'opération aujourd'hui c'est sans
doute pas à faire un cadeau aux salariés
alors que la rédaction actuelle nous y
forcerait dès le premier janvier 2024
les forceraient sans doute à faire une
très mauvaise opération financière mais
au-delà serait évidemment totalement
anachronique alors qu'on est exactement
en train de faire le contraire c'est à
dire de racheter les minoritaires y
compris certains d'ailleurs détenus dans
le cadre de l'actionnaire un salarié
Vous le savez aujourd'hui l'État détient
déjà 90% du capital et pourrait
légalement racheter les 10% restants du
fait d'un certain nombre de recours qui
ont été déposés l'État le gouvernement
s'est engagé à attendre que ces recours
soient jugés vous l'avez dit madame la
sénatrice début mais avant
au cas où ces recours serait rejetés de
procéder à l'acquisition de la totalité
du capital vous avez voté dans l'article
1 le fait que l'État doit être 100% du
capital et vous nous demandiez pourquoi
cet amendement était indispensable
aujourd'hui parce que du fait de cet
article 1 si jamais nous souhaitions si
jamais l'entreprise souhaitait si jamais
l'actionnaire acceptait de procéder à la
mise en place d'un dispositif
d'actionnaires salariés en 2024 2025 ou
2026 ça serait tout simplement
impossible du fait de l'article 1 que
vous avez voté c'est pour ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle cet amendement que
nous proposons aujourd'hui au Sénat rend
la possibilité ouverte
sans nécessairement un passage au
Parlement à la direction de proposer un
programme d'actionnaire un salarié
évidemment sans obligation de temps
niaurée pour laisser à l'entreprise le
temps de se dirait remettre en forme
avant d'y procéder merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
la Commission a exprimer un avis de
sagesse parce que c'est affaire est en
effet très difficile et très sensible
nous avons un immense respect pour
l'entreprise EDF ce qui nous a conduit à
soutenir un amendement de notre collègue
Victorin Lurel qui fait d'EDF et on
retrouve dans le texte de la commission
une entreprise d'intérêt national ça n'a
pas de signification juridique autre que
le reconnaître que la communauté des
salariés dans l'histoire de déesse a
bien fait son travail
82000 salariés en seins salariés sont
été actionnés ou sont actionnaires de DF
aujourd'hui c'est l'expression d'un
engagement dans leur entreprise qui
conforte cette image de communauté c'est
la raison pour laquelle la Commission
souhaitait et avait proposé un texte qui
donnait cette possibilité en l'encadrant
dans une période courte et c'est le
problème de la période courte qui
apparaît avec force madame l'avare l'a
fait valoir dans le débat en commission
nous avons trop d'inconnus celles que
j'ai évoquées à la tribune sur l'avenir
du marché lannir de l'organisation le
marché et de l'énergie électrique je
suis très optimiste il est il sera
nécessairement en croissance parce que
la décarbonation de notre société passe
par l'électricité donc je n'ai
simplement aucun doute sur le fait qu'il
nous faudra produire de plus en plus
d'électricité et que l'entreprise qui a
le son fils de l'expérience de plus de
50 ans de 58 réacteurs nucléaires et
quand même mieux placé que n'importe
quel autre entreprise pour conquérir des
positions nouvelles fortes mais ce n'est
pas encore dans un cadre clair et donc
nous avons besoin de savoir si il y aura
des contrats d'achat de long terme
motorisés s'il y aura des contrats par
différence s'il y aura la possibilité
d'acheter des parts de centrales
nucléaires pour avoir des droits de
tirage comme excelsium en profite je
sais de quoi je parle je l'ai mis en
place comme ministre de l'Industrie au
siècle précédent donc nous avons toute
une série de questions qui méritent
d'obtenir des réponses avant que
d'engager l'économie des salariés dans
ce qui reste toujours une aventure vous
savez très bien que lorsque l'on fait de
la publicité pour une offre de public de
voilà on dit
les
performances passées n'engagent pas
l'avenir et donc pour protéger les
salariés nous souhaitons
sagesse sagesse positive à l'égard de
l'amendement du Gouvernement sur
rapporteur je vais vous surveiller
attentivement
un programme de
ma fonction
si on parle de drame le mien est
terrible aussi vous savez
monsieur moto g vous avez merci madame
la Présidente nous n'avons pas eu
d'explication claire du ministre sur les
conséquences juridiques de cet
amendement
sur les concessions hydrauliques dans le
cadre européen
l'analyse que nous en faisons c'est
qu'avec cette mesure vous lancez une
torpille contre le groupe EDF je pèse
mes mots vous allez devoir mais je pense
que c'est peut-être votre intention
première détacher l'hydraulique du
groupe EDF donc démanteler et ce sera le
commencement peut-être de la fin à
l'instar de ce qui s'est passé pour
l'entreprise nationale qui était Gaz de
France à une époque alors voilà cela
nous laisse pas de de nous inquiéter ce
débat est crucial s'il reste une part de
capital autre que d'État
au sein du groupe on va être vous allez
être confronté à cette question là je
pense que les territoires vont peu
apprécier de voir mis en concurrence
peut-être par obligation les concessions
hydrauliques sur le territoire national
est-ce qu'encore une fois vous pouvez
nous préciser votre analyse par rapport
à ce point extrêmement important merci
pour Monsieur le Ministre j'avoue que
son explication ne m'a pas vraiment
convaincu ou rassuré et je reste
toujours très sceptique quand je lis
l'exposé des motifs de cette amendement
qui dit quand même que donc l'amande
vise à ce que les anciens salariés
pourront donc être actionnaires d'EDF
deux sortes à ce que les salariés du
groupe ne soient pas forcés de vendre
leur titre lors du départ de
l'entreprise mais enfin ce que je ne
crois pas c'est que vous venez de nous
réexpliquer que vous allez monter à 100%
du capital donc à un moment ils ont déjà
vendu leur titre ils peuvent toujours
être dans l'entreprise et donc l'exposer
des motifs semble dire qu'ils ont encore
ces titres et qu'il ne seraient pas
forcé de les vendre au moment où ils
partent alors je il y a quelque chose
qui est pas très clair et c'est toute la
procédure de mise en oeuvre en fait
c'est soit l'État détient 100% du
capital et on le dit et ça peut
permettre et pour tout un tas de raisons
que j'ai exposé tout à l'heure avoir sa
pertinence notamment pour venir
permettre le financement de ces
investissements conséquents qui ne vont
pas permettre le financement de
dividende soit on dit qu'effectivement
on veut apporter quelque chose assez
salarié qui ont fait l'histoire du
groupe qui ont fait l'histoire de notre
politique
énergétique et notre notamment notre
politique nucléaire mais à ce moment-là
faut que ce soit clair pour eux et là
j'avoue que ça ne l'est pas
bien je vais donc monsieur le ministre
vous souhaiter répondre
vous le pouvez je comprends que les
débats doivent s'accélérer mais un je
enfin le fait de rendre l'actionnariat
salarié optionnel ou obligatoire tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui prévu dans la
rédaction de la commission nous
changeons rien aux questions que vous
vous posez monsieur le sénateur donc on
va s'assurer que j'ai bien compris votre
question et si vous vous autorisez on
répondra à par écrit mais le fait que
l'actionnaire soit optionnel ou ou
obligatoire à mon avis ne changeant rien
les débats qu'on a par ailleurs sur les
concessions hydrauliques sur lesquelles
il faut évidemment qu'on soit
extrêmement ferme donc je vais essayer
de clarifier effectivement
nous achetons 100% du capital point et
donc si le jugement du tribunal des
muets est conforme à ce à quoi on
s'attend on aura dans la foulée la
capacité d'acheter les 5% du capital
restant l'état détiendra 100% du capital
point si dans deux ans trois ans quatre
ans cinq ans la situation de
l'entreprise est dans une meilleure
situation on l'autorise par cet
amendement éventuellement à envisager et
à mettre en oeuvre un accord
d'actionnariat salarié sans avoir à
repasser par le Parlement
et cet accord d'actionnariat salarié
comme c'était le cas dans l'accord
précédent permet à la fois de
aux salariés d'acheter des actions du
groupe et de les détenir et de les
conserver
ultérieurement au cas où il quitterait
le groupe par exemple pour prendre la
retraite donc c'est juste pour
reproduire en avant des dispositions qui
existaient d'ores et déjà dans la corde
actionnaires salariés aujourd'hui et
c'est en aucun cas évidemment l'idée de
prolonger les actions détenues
aujourd'hui par des salariés au-delà de
l'achat qui je le confirme passera bien
à 100% du capital jusqu'à jusqu'à ce
qu'on en décide autrement dans le cadre
de la gestion de l'entreprise et dans le
cadre d'un accord d'actionnaire incarner
merci Monsieur gay
merci madame la Présidente comme quoi
l'actionnariat salarié c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ce qu'on nous vend tous
les jours puisque a priori pour vous ça
devrait même remplacer le salaire
intéressant participation à qui on a
salarié c'est bon pour vous et les
salaires pas du tout
cette affaire d'actionnariat salariés
sur EDF on va les défendre parce que
c'est une compas où ça Sion il faut se
rappeler l'histoire c'est pas historique
l'action derrière le salarié chez EDF ça
a commencé en 2005 lorsque vous avez
décidé d'ouvrir au capital et donc
c'était en réalité une compensation pour
les salariés 130 000 à l'époque sont
devenus actionnaires salariés et ils
auront perdu de l'argent parce que ceux
qui ont racheté le titre à 30 euros et
qui seront obligés de le revendre à 11
ou 12 euros auront bien perdu de
l'argent et donc là vous expliquer et
c'est pour ça qu'il vous aura attaqué
notamment sur une question et les
dernières décisions que vous avez prises
notamment les 20 Tera Watters
supplémentaires qu'on fait perdre 8
milliards quatre et qui ont fait baisser
en réalité le prix de l'action au moment
où il est sorti en bourse et c'est pour
ça que vous allez pouvoir le racheter
entre 11 et 12 euros donc là vous nous
expliquez vous êtes en capacité en
quelque sorte de spolier les
actionnaires salariés aujourd'hui vous
allez reprendre 100% et peut-être demain
vous allez leur proposer
de redevenir actionnaire salarié il y
aura un problème quand même ce ministre
vous voyez bien quand même personne ne
comprend rien à ce que vous êtes en
train de faire je vous remercie merci
donc sur cet amendement du gouvernement
qui a Monsieur cavinet merci Madame la
président de Monsieur le Ministre bon
effectivement comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans la discussion générale le
groupe de l'Union centriste est
particulièrement attaché à ce que il y
ait le développement de l'actionnaire
salarié qu'il est aussi des notions de
partage de la valeur et c'est vrai que
le les propositions du rapporteur nous
semblait empruntent de bon sens compte
tenu de la discussion qui vient
d'évoquer le groupe va s'abstenir je
propose donc les trois amendements qui
proposent le retour au tarif réglementé
le premier sur le mode de calcul les le
deuxième pour le retour au tarif
règlementé pour toutes les collectivités
et les TPE PME et le dernier un
amendement de repli pour les
collectivités juste sur les TRV et la
reine parce qu'il y a évidemment un lien
de cause à effet d'ailleurs je pense que
il faudra regarder sur les 60 milliards
d'endettement jusqu'à réellement coûté
la reine qui a été voté en 2010 dans le
cadre de la loi norme et je crois pas
que c'était un gouvernement socialiste à
l'époque non il y a une vraie question
autour de la reine et pour répondre tout
à l'heure à l'interpellation de Monsieur
la rapporteur c'est vrai qu'il y a des
acteurs alternatifs qui produisent mais
sur les 90 aujourd'hui il y en a deux
véritables c'est engie et total énergie
tout le reste sont des facturateurs et
sont en réalité des suceurs de sang
d'EDF permettez-moi de le dire comme ça
et donc s'il n'y avait pas d'arène et si
on suspendait la reine c'est 88 acteurs
alternatifs tomberaient c'est comme ça
et d'ailleurs pour vous dire il n'y a
pas que le groupe communiste ou Fabien
geckel de demande j'ai vu que le
rapporteur monsieur Armand qui est
député Renaissance demande la suspension
très rapide de la reine vous voyez donc
quand il y a des gens qui commencent à
travailler sur la question il se rendent
compte de aussi de ce système et il ne
demande pas le rénover il demande à le
suspendre et sur le retour au tarif
réglementé juste une question parce que
les gens doivent savoir ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus il y a d'arènes
moins il y a des traitements et donc
c'est vrai que les acteurs alternatifs
aujourd'hui ils doivent aller se fournir
pour 70% sur la reine à 40 euros et
après en réalité sur le marché donc
comme le prix à dévisser cette année ils
ont été des fois 200 300 400 500 euros
de mégawattheure avec un pic tout le
monde connaît au mois d'août à 1200 mais
en réalité aujourd'hui nous avons un
problème c'est que depuis cinq ans ce
n'est pas l'empilement des coûts et le
coût réel c'est que on prend en compte
pour l'augmentation du tarif léguementé
la partie du taux des traitements pour
les acteurs alternatifs qui doivent
aller se fournir sur le marché et donc
en réalité on ne peut plus avec le tarif
le commenté le coût réel de l'énergie on
paye en réalité aujourd'hui les
dividendes des actionnaires des acteurs
alternatifs c'est ça la réalité et donc
le tarif réglementé il augmente non pas
sur les coûts réels mais sur cette part
des traitements et donc sur le trading
du marché c'est ça la réalité depuis 5
ans et c'est pour ça que ça dévisse et
c'est pour ça que tarif règlementé il a
augmenté en réalité beaucoup ces deux
dernières années mais bien avant depuis
2017 il ne cesse d'augmenter tous les
six mois donc il faut en revenir sur un
tarif réglementé qui s'applique sur les
coûts et il faut en finir avec la reine
qui raquette d'un côté EDF et qui
raquette aussi les usagers c'est ça la
réalité voilà je vous remercie et donc
j'ai présenté les trois en même temps
merci bien monsieur leur rapporteur va
donner son avis sur les trois en même
temps
madame la Présidente la commission n'est
pas favorable ces trois amendements
parce qu'ils sont en opposition avec ce
que nous avons établi d'accord à corps
gouvernementaux transposé en droit en
français et en particulier dans le code
de l'énergie sur la capacité d'ouvrir
les trve à l'ensemble des consommateurs
sont justiciables de des terres les
résidentiels c'est particulier et les
professionnels dès lors des
professionnels dès lors qu'ils ont moins
de 10 salariés moins de 2 millions de
chiffre d'affaires alors on a envie
d'aider tout le monde sauf que c'est
assez coûteux j'ai cru comprendre et
d'autre part alors ça c'est un premier
problème nous serions en contradiction
avec les règles européennes ensuite on
est fait on irait subventionné on irait
casser des contrats qui sont établis
actuellement entre des entreprises et
des
les fournisseurs alternatifs privés qui
seraient fondé à dire puisque la loi
nous oblige à prendre en charge des
tervee hors EDF évidemment des tervu
d'alternatifs à ce moment-là ils sont
retournés faire le gouvernement en
disant puisque vous nous Cassez des
contrats où on gagnait notre vie pour
nous obliger à vendre moins cher ensuite
on va voir ce que veut dire moins cher
remboursez-nous alors là ça coûterait
bonbon et puis troisième remarque le
TRV est calculé par la creux par un
empilement et par un jeu assez complexe
en effet de lissage dans le temps et
nous ne pourrions avoir ces prix que
dans une dans une perspective assez
longue madame l'avare qui connaît mieux
le sujet que moi pourraient expliquer il
faut
un recul d'environ 12 mois je crois pour
pouvoir établir des terres nouveaux donc
on est dans un système qui est à peu
près non praticable et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je propose de se borner à
limiter au 36 kVA à faire à supprimer
les 36 qui avait à dans le cadre de
l'Europe monsieur le ministre votre avis
sur ces trois amendements rapidement un
avis similaire j'aimerais ajouter que
cette article en fait a été adoptée en
commission lors de l'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale l'article qui
généralisait le TRV à tous les à tous
les consommateurs
vous n'y êtes pour rien vous n'en avez
hérité mais il reste pour nous un casier
un cavalier total à cette proposition de
loi et sans rapport si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi avec le schmilblick
cela dit il est là aujourd'hui il vous
est arrivé comme tel il faut donc qu'on
en discute et c'est vrai que vous avez
limité son coût en en limitant les faits
au TPE en disant voilà c'est les TPE
toutes les TPE qu'elles soient en fait
consommatrices individuelle comme vous
et moi ou qu'elle soit consommatrice int
ensive comme certaines boulangers dont
on a beaucoup parlé j'en comprends j'en
comprends la logique c'est moins coûteux
évidemment que ce qu'avait voté
l'assemblée alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
de la certitude sur le coup tout
simplement parce que ce type de
dispositif il est exposé au marché et
que son coût varie toutes les semaines
en fonction du prix de marché c'est
d'ailleurs un de ces dangers
c'est que vous exposez alors soit les
finances d'EDF au choix
si EDF qui paye soit les finances de
l'État à un coup de marché qui lui on
l'a vu depuis un an et demi est
extrêmement volatile
et donc on décidant de supprimer le
plafond du TRV alors soit pour toutes
les entreprises de l'ordre de 20
milliards j'avais dit 18 et pourquoi
j'avais dit 18 à l'époque parce que
l'écart entre le prix de marché
quand j'étais à l'Assemblée nationale et
l'écart du TRV étaient de l'ordre de 200
rôles mégawatts pour une consommation de
l'ensemble des entreprises concernées
par l'amendement brun de l'ordre de
santerawatts donc on arrivait à 20
milliards 18 pour être précis
aujourd'hui votre amendement écoute
moins cher pour deux raisons d'abord ce
que vous en limitez l'impact
on est sur une consommation de l'ordre
de 20 TW et puis l'écart a lui aussi
baissé parce que le prix de marché avait
baissé donc aujourd'hui votre amendement
il coûte à peu près un milliard d'euros
50 euros d'écart entre le TRV et le prix
le marché pour à peu près 21 mais si
demain ou après-demain le prix de marché
explose et ben il coûtera 2 3 4 5 6 7
milliards d'euros et il faudra qu'on en
assume les conséquences soit directement
sur les comptes d'EDF dont on souhaite
aujourd'hui tous qu'ils soient préservés
soit sur les comptes de l'État dont on
reconnaîtra tous je pense qui sont quand
même pas dans un état fantastique c'est
les raisons pour laquelle moi j'étais le
gouvernement était défavorable à
l'ensemble de cette généralisation du
TRV qu'on y a substituer des aides éner
qui certes ont été critiqués mais dont
il faut reconnaître aujourd'hui quelle
fonctionnent on a des pensées à peu près
de 150 millions d'euros sur notre notre
bouclier tarifaire on a dépend pas non
sur les sur le guichet ouvert depuis
janvier on a dépensé entre 50 et 80
milliards d'euros sur le bouclier
tarifaire on a aujourd'hui beaucoup
aidés les ménages beaucoup aidés les
entreprises y compris les énergo
intensives on va continuer à le faire je
préfère qu'on le fasse dans le cadre
actuel que dans le cadre de cet article
merci monsieur le ministre je profite de
votre intervention ce que j'ai bien
entendu et je vais je veux bien me faire
confirmer ce que vous avez évoqué sur
TRV tarif de marché et la grande
fluctuation vous avez évoqué des
boulangers mais il y a malheureusement
pas que
et donc je pense qu'il est important
d'envoyer un message
au public concerné puisque un certain
nombre de fournisseurs à l'automne
dernier ont écrit alors abonnés en
disant écoutez on peut plus tenir les
tarifs
que qui nous liait de manière
contractuelle
envolée des prix ça a été multiplié
parfois par 5 6 7 8 et puis aujourd'hui
donc à ce moment-là il aurait été
proposé de signer de nouveaux contrats
parfois contrariée
dont aujourd'hui l'opérateur dit
lui-même a même maintenant je ne peux
plus y toucher
je le dis parce que comme il se trouve
que ce fournisseur a trois lettres dont
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
il va y avoir besoin d'une chose on
clarifie la situation d'abord l'état
aura la main et à défaut vous l'avez dit
soit l'opérateur le fournisseur
revoit ses conditions on nous dit que
c'est pas possible j'entends soit l'état
viendra en compensation mais il faut le
dire aujourd'hui parce que derrière il y
a des entreprises vous le savez et je
pense que l'État a un message envoyé
pour garantir un traitement je dirais
équitable des situations puisque cette
situation elle est provoquée en tant
qu'elle est étrangère aux entreprises
voilà monsieur le ministre que je
voulais appeler votre attention sur ce
sujet qui est un sujet majeur
bien maintenant la parole est à Monsieur
monte
[Musique]
c'était possible depuis le 1er janvier
2023 je vous remercie monsieur cap
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
j'ai pas le temps de répliquer à mon
collègueurel je partage avec lui en
revanche le fait que on a besoin d'une
filière nucléaire brillante qui permette
même de céder de l'électricité à nos
voisins et là-dessus nous sommes en
accord je voulais revenir sur ces trois
rendements et plus globalement sur
l'article 3 bis évidemment on ne peut
qu'être favorable dans le principe à
l'extension de du tarif réglementé c'est
difficile d'être contre cependant
d'un autre côté faut quand même aussi
être responsable
particulièrement pour les membres de la
commission des finances c'est quand même
de l'argent public évidemment on peut
étendre à tout le monde le tarif
réglementé nous y sommes tous favorables
mais derrière ce sont les finances
publiques qui sont mises en cause et
donc je voudrais formuler trois
remarques à ce stade certaines que j'ai
déjà formulé lors de la commission des
finances la première et le ministre
vient de le dire
cet article 3 vis ne figurerait pas dans
le texte initial alors les auteurs font
ce qu'ils veulent il n'en reste pas
moins que ça ressemble fortement à un
cavalier législatif qui n'avait rien à
voir avec le texte initial relatif à la
nationalisation de DF deuxième remarque
là-dessus nous avons déjà eu des
échanges en commission des finances avec
le président de la commission des
finances il est incontestable que quel
que soit le payeur et le ministre vient
de le dire au final c'est le
contribuable qui paiera et donc
incontestablement même si pour des
raisons de procédure on peut plaider le
contraire
incontestablement cet article aurait dû
être frappé de l'article 40 et il aurait
dû être jugé il recevable de façon
incontestable puisqu'il grève
nécessairement les finances publiques et
ma troisième remarque découle des deux
premières cet article 3 bis n'a rien à
faire ici il devrait plutôt s'intégrer
dans un pl F afin que nous puissions
avoir une étude d'impact sérieux sur le
coup de cette mesure monsieur gay
merci Madame la président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues on est
d'accord que les tarifs réglementés ça a
existait pendant 50 ans pour tout le
monde
résidentiel entreprise collectivité tout
le monde y avait accès ça marchait
plutôt bien
j'ai jamais vu personne sans plaindre à
l'époque
premièrement deuxième chose monsieur le
rapporteur déjà répondu nous dit c'est
les règles européennes oui mais tout le
monde dirait des roge tout le monde
demande des dérogations pourquoi nous
nous demandons pas une dérogation pour
protéger nos collectivités nos petites
entreprises en leur permettant le tarif
réglementé par leur imposant s'il y a
des collectivités des entreprises qui
souhaitent rester dans des contrats à
marcher libre tant mieux pour elle mais
celle qui voit leur facture exploser on
est tous élus de départements vous citez
les commerçants les boulangers des
collectivités et on est qu'au début de
la crise ça va encore durer deux ans et
demi les factures vont continuer à
pleuvoir troisième problème c'est le
Ministre et où il va falloir que quand
même un moment donné quelque part au 30
juin
5 millions de personnes auront pu accès
au tarif réglementés du gaz les
particuliers en pleine crise du gaz
est-ce que nous allons laisser faire
cette chose ou pas est-ce que nous nous
allons quand même prendre une initiative
ou parlementaire au gouvernemental pour
les prolonger en pleine crise ou est-ce
qu'on va tout et tous les laisser sans
foncer sur le prix du marché il faudra
répondre et puis dernière chose monsieur
le ministre
vous dites ça coûte cher certes quand on
a proposé le retour au tarif réglementé
pour toutes les collectivités on départ
on nous a dit 60 milliards puis quand il
y a une étude 3 milliards et demi 3
milliards et demi et vous l'avez dit
combien en bouclier tarifaire sécurité
filet de sécurité arène supplémentaire
rien qu'en dernier avec les trous de la
raquette 50 à 80 milliards donc 3
milliards et demi pour le retour au
tarif règlementé et 50 à 80 milliards
que vous avez jeté à la poubelle et
donner aux acteurs alternatifs voilà la
réalité
je me suis brouillé
merci madame la Présidente bon moi je
voterai avec mon groupe c'est
propositions dont j'admets qui auraient
leur place dans un PLF très très
volontiers mais je voulais en profiter
aussi pour répondre à mon collègue Capu
qui nous prête beaucoup de pouvoir et je
leur remercie c'est vrai que 50
milliards de grands carénage 56
milliards pour 6 EPR dans l'estimation
gouvernementale parce que quand même le
père un coup de 19 milliards mais on va
en faire 6 pour 56 milliards et 64
milliards de dettes c'est aussi un tout
petit peu d'argent donc 3 milliards pour
les tarifs réglementés de vente ça me
paraît tout à fait acceptable
quelques réponses quand même d'abord au
fait que le gouvernement pense aussi il
l'a dit à l'Assemblée nationale que cet
article est un cavalier et qu'il est en
plus il aurait peut-être dû en tout cas
pu être jugé une éligible au titre de
l'article 40 mais il ne s'immisent pas
dans les discussions au sein de la
commission des finances ni celle de
l'Assemblée nationale ni celle
évidemment du Sénat pour éventuellement
se réserver se réserver le droit de de
porter cette controverse devant le
Conseil constitutionnel on verra
bon monsieur gay vous m'excusez si je
vous réponds pas sur le gaz on passe
déjà pas mal de temps sur l'électricité
aujourd'hui vous aurez quand même
l'occasion de discuter dans le cas de la
programmation pluralienne de l'énergie
de toutes ces discussions importantes
sur la manière dont on doit envisager la
fourniture d'électricité de gaz et plus
généralement d'énergie en France pour
les années qui viennent et vous l'aurez
en temps voulu
juste quelques chiffres qui vont me
permettre j'espère à la fois de préciser
la question du rapporteur général Luçon
et les questions que vous avez
mentionnées en passant sur le coup des
différents dispositifs quand même
bouclier tarifaire pour les particuliers
plus TPE plus petite collectivité
inférieure à 36 kg en pair ce que vous
proposez aujourd'hui
d'élargir au TPE quelle qu'elle soit
ça a limité à 15% la hausse des prix au
lieu de 120% sur deux ans le coût pour
les finances publiques c'est 30
milliards en 2022 et 45 en 2023 y
compris les collectivités territoriales
dont vous parliez le cap à 280 euros le
mégawatt ça c'est important monsieur
rapporteur général vous ne lisiez
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on n'est pas
aujourd'hui couvert par le TRV on a
adopté d'ailleurs sur la suggestion d'un
certain nombre d'entre vous un cap à 280
euros le mégawatt pour le prix de
l'électricité pour toutes les TPE qui
vous l'avez dit ont eu la malchance
d'avoir un contrat qui s'interrompait à
l'automne dernier et qui se sont
retrouvés du coup à négocier un peu le
couteau sous la tempe des contrats qui
étaient bien au dessus de ceux qu'ils
avaient auparavant et donc c'est 280
euros l'omégawatt sont intégrés en
moyenne sur Tannée dans les factures qui
sont actuellement envoyés par les
fournisseurs d'énergie y compris pour un
certain nombre de boulangers ou d'autres
TPE concernés
on a aussi adopté un amortisseur
électricité pour les PME et pour les
collectivités territoriales alors ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais c'est
cohérent avec la réglementation
européenne qui fait comprendre en charge
50% du surcoût au-delà de 180 euros le
Megawatt et ça ça coûte entre 2 et 3
milliards d'euros à la collectivité
nationale et enfin pour les ce qu'on
appelle les énergo intensifs donc les
pour les plus grandes entreprises qui
consomment beaucoup d'énergie un guichet
qui permet aujourd'hui à un certain
nombre d'entreprises de faire valoir la
hausse de leur facture d'électricité ou
de gaz et de demander des aides qui à ce
stade correspondent à 250 millions
d'euros attribués depuis quelques
semaines et sans doute une accélération
assez forte puisqu'on voit
l'accélération importante depuis 10
jours avec les factures de 2023 qui
arrivent on a ajouté à votre d'ailleurs
suggestion un filet de sécurité de 430
millions d'euros adoptés à l'été 2022
pour les collectivités dans le cadre de
la loi de financement rectificatif bref
tout ça ça nous coûte beaucoup d'argent
on peut en être fier parce qu'au fond
l'inflation en France est inférieure
ailleurs en Europe et les entreprises
ont plutôt bien passé la crise
contrairement à nos craintes mais soyons
conscient quand même que tout ça nous
coûte beaucoup d'argent merci je vais
mettre au voie maintenant l'ensemble de
la proposition de loi pour lequel je
suis saisie pour laquelle je suis saisie
d'un demande de ce que tu as publié par
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
le scrutin est ouvert votant 343 exprimé
329 pour 206 contre 123 le Sénat a
adopté
[Musique]